Hey Wisecrack, Jared here and today we’re
taking a fresh look at the 1995 classic that
seamlessly combined mind-bending metaphysical
themes and cartoon boobs- Ghost in the Shell.
Yeah, we know there’s a new version out,
but apparently they forgot to put in a lot
of the brainy stuff so we decided to talk
about the original.
Many have weighed in over the years on what
the film says about the line between human
and machine but that’s not what we’re
talking about today.
Instead, we’re going to examine the film’s
warning about humanity’s potentially fatal
flaw and its roadmap for a more evolved civilization.
Ghost in the Shell is probably one of the
most philosophicaly complex animated films
out there, so a big shout out to Naruto Online
for sponsoring this video and supporting us
as we tackle this cultural milestone.
Since some of the philosophy we’ll be covering
can get a bit confusing, stick around til
the end to hear us explain a key lesson using
the world of Naruto.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on The Philosophy
of Ghost in the Shell.
And as always, spoilers ahead.
Ghost in the Shell had a huge impact on sci-fi.
Works such as Ex Machina,The Matrix, and Westworld
echo not only the film’s aesthetics but
also the theme of mankind vs. technology.
We often see this as a warning that technology
will take over and/or alter humanity for the
worse.
I’m not talking about clickbait or selfies.
I’m talking about this.
And this.
You know, classic robot overlord stuff.
However, Ghost in the Shell is different.
While it’s set up to be a typical battle
between man and his creation, the resolution
is not one side triumphing over the other,
but a synthesis between the two.
Don’t remember?
Can’t blame you - it’s probably been awhile.
Here’s a quick refresher.
The film centers around Major Motoko Kusanagi,a
cyborg government agent working for Section
9 - basically a black ops unit.
Section 9 pursues a mysterious entity known
as the Puppet Master, who employs ghost-hacking
to monkey around with people’s memories and force
them to do its bidding.
This super-hacker turns out to be a spy program
originally called Project 2501, which was
secretly developed by Section 6.
They’re an intelligence division - sort
of like the CIA.
Section 6 lost control of their creation after
it spontaneously developed self-awareness
by swimming in the vast ocean of the digital
world.
When Kusanagi finally catches up to the Puppet
Master, it makes a rather forward proposal:
they should merge consciousnesses and create
a new, unique being.
She accepts, and the film ends with the new
entity - call it the Kusanuppet Master - contemplating
what to do next.
Maybe a vacation?
The confrontation and resolution of these
two forces - human and digital consciousnesses
- reflects German philosopher Georg Hegel’s
vision of progress.
To Hegel, conflict progresses human history.
Every development, from the time of our illustrious
forefathers to the present day, is caused
by forces that clash and create something
new.
This is Hegel’s “dialectics” in a nutshell.
But before we get into that, we need to show
how Hegel’s fundamental ideas help build
the setting of Ghost in the Shell.
First and foremost, Hegel’s philosophy is
driven by the belief that the world operates
on rational principles and that the true nature
of reality is knowable.
Kusanagi is defined by this philosophical
idealism.
She is driven by dissatisfaction with her
limited perspective,
and is convinced that there is
a more perfect reality available to her.
As such, the film treats the marriage of Kusanagi’s
human consciousness and the Puppet Master’s
artificial nature with a certain optimism,
and Hegel’s system of dialectics explains
why.
But first, I want to distinguish Hegel’s
dialectics from the way the term is more commonly
understood.
In classical philosophy, dialectics are a
form of argumentative discourse designed to
ferret out contradictions and arrive at a
better understanding of truth.
You start with an argument, called a thesis,
which is met by a counter-argument called
an anti-thesis.
The end result may be a refutation of the
original proposition, an affirmation of the
counter-argument, or a synthesis of the assertions
that results in a better understanding of
the subject.
Think Socratic Method, or a lawyer cross-examining
a witness.
The purpose is to learn the truth.
In Hegel’s system, dialectics is more than
just philosophical inquiry - they are the
very mechanism by which humans progress, both
on an individual level and as a collective.
When one force confronts another force, something
new ultimately emerges.
At the heart of the film is a dialectic of
the human and digital worlds.
In one corner, we have Kusanagi and her human
mind.
Her various memories and experiences combine
to make her a unique individual.
And yet she feels constrained by her own limited
personal identity.
In the other corner we have the Puppet Master,
who sprang forth from the vast informational
resources of cyber-reality and therefore possesses
the broader understanding that Kusanagi seeks.
But the Puppet Master too feels limited, by
its lack of personal identity.
In short, each has what the other needs.
Other films have us trained to think that
when technology gets a little too big for
its britches it need to be put in its place
so humanity can be preserved.
But through the lens of Hegel's master/slave
dialectic, this meeting of the minds should
have no winner.
Imagine a feudal lord of the middle ages and
the serfs bound to work his fields.
The lord is the master - he can force the
serfs to toil away because he controls all
the agriculture in the area.
The serfs are his slaves - peasants who can't
afford land of their own.
They work their asses off while the lord sits
back with a refreshing drink.
Sounds great for the lord, right?
The problem is, as the serfs labor they get
better and better at farming, while the master
learns nothing new.
He stagnates, while the serfs become more
powerful due to their valuable knowledge.
This, according to Hegel, is what leads the
oppressed to overcome their masters.
Still not making sense? Well, stick around till the end to hear it explained in the context of Naruto.
Examples of oppressive masters and usurping
slaves resonate throughout Ghost in the Shell.
Section 6, ostensibly pulling the Puppet Master’s
strings, remains antiquated, stagnant, and
stuck in the politics of the old world.
They preserve some power through their mastery
of Project 2501, but gain nothing while the
Puppet Master slowly gains sentience as it
labors for them.
Separately, the Puppet Master acts as master
when it uses its ghost-hacking ability to
hijack others and force them to do its bidding.
We see this early in the film when Section
9 interrogates the garbageman and learns that
he was brainwashed into believing he was spying
on his wife, when in fact he was merely the
Puppet Master’s tool.
But the Puppet Master's efforts are constantly thwarted
and it remains unable to escape the terms of its bondage.
Similarly, Section 9’s typical M.O. is classic
“master” behavior; they use lethal force
to accomplish their goals, leaving no room
for compromise.
The first time we see Batou, he’s bragging
that Section 9 has the authority to kill.
And Aramaki’s approach to the Puppet Master
is to destroy it if Kusanagi can’t secure it.
Ultimately, none of this is productive.
It just makes it harder for Section 9 to understand
the Puppet Master’s true nature and prolongs
Kusanagi’s journey to enlightenment.
The preferred result when two opposing forces
clash is synthesis, which Hegel refers to
as sublation.
He means something very specific: it’s combination
without loss.
The result is a unique, superior idea that
incorporates and accommodates both perspectives.
That’s what the Puppet Master is proposing
when he suggests that he and Kusanagi merge.
A cyborg is a great example of this.
A cyborg is neither wholly man or machine.
It’s a synthesis of man and machine - encompassing
both, it becomes something new.
Sublation is crucial because it helps avoid
the stagnation that occurs when a person,
idea, or whatever becomes too insulated.
Looking at Section 9, we see that the team
was composed with dialectical principles in mind.
When Togusa asks Kusanagi why he, a non-augmented
human, is included on the team of cyborg bad-asses,
Kusanagi explains that his uniqueness makes
the group stronger.
The Puppet Master too is aware of the problem
of stagnation, and that’s why he needs the
constraints that Kusanagi feels fettered by.
This
is reminiscent of a species from another classic
series - The Borg, from Star Trek.
The Borg are an awesome villain and I’d
use any excuse to bring them up, but they
actually illustrate what we’re talking about
pretty well.
The Borg is a cybernetic race that travels
the galaxy assimilating other species into
a collective mind.
Why do they do this?
It’s the same reason.
Without diversity, the weaknesses of the race
will inbreed and compound, rendering their
civilization vulnerable.
Obviously, from the perspective of the assimilated,
there's some loss.
The Borg get your smarts and fresh genetic
material, and all you get is a new, modern look.
But from the perspective of the Borg, it's
a story of developing consciousness.
Sublation is the climax of Ghost in the Shell
- not a battle to the death, but rather a
synthesis that results in a stronger, more
evolved being.
For Hegel, the progress of human history happens
through conflicts like these, both on an individual
level and on a much larger scale.
Everytime we make any kind of advance through
these dialectics, be it in science, art, or
what have you, the world enters a new state
of affairs that should represent an improvement
over what came before.
Hegel calls this new state ‘geist.”
The word can be translated as “mind,”
“spirit,” or even...wait for it, “ghost.”
Soo..
Geist in the shell, anyone?
At the end of the film, after Kusanagi and
the Puppet Master have merged, we have a new
state of affairs in which this new type of
being exists.
Call it a new era, call it evolution, call
it what you will - it’s geist, following
its trajectory towards an improved world.
The film hints at this in the climactic battle
scene, when tank-fire obliterates the names
of less evolved creatures in the Tree of Life,
stopping at the top on “hominis.”
This symbolizes that evolution must continue
even past human beings.
This is why Ghost in the Shell’s message
is so unique from other films in the genre.
It’s not about what will happen
if we do merge with our technology, it’s
what will happen if we don’t.
The message is to interact with the world,
resolve our contradictions with it, and emerge
stronger than we were before.
Clinging to our beliefs about what we are
will only prevent us from becoming what we
can be.
Put another way, “resistance is futile”
may sound bad coming from the Borg, but according
to Hegel, sublation is a necessary towards
progress.
So it just may be true.
Hey guys thanks for watching.
Still a bit confused about Hegel’s Master/Slave
dialectic?
I don’t blame you.
Hegel is pretty freakin difficult.
But luckily, if you’re a fan of Naruto,
I’ve got another way to explain it.
Keep in mind, this scenario is entirely hypothetical.
Let’s start at the beginning.
Naruto desperately wants recognition from
the people of The Hidden Leaf Village by becoming
Hokage, or the master ninja of the village.
Let’s say that Naruto uses sweet Jutsus
and the nine tailed fox spirit to FORCE people
to make him Hokage.
By coercing the villagers to submit to him,
Naruto has gained mastery over them.
In Hegel’s terms they will have become Naruto’s
slaves or bondsmen.
Well, the problem is...just because he’s
now Hokage, that doesn’t mean he actually
has the skills.
That doesn’t occur until hundreds of episodes
later after he defeats Pain.
In fact, at this point, the villagers would
have no choice but to to do the bulk of the
protecting and ninja duties while Naruto just
sits back and takes all the credit.
In other words, if the people are having to
fight invaders, build defenses, and craft
weapons, then THEY are the ones gaining the
skills becoming of sweet sweet Hokage-ness.
Essentially, Naruto will never get any better
at being a Hokage, while his “subordinates”
are becoming more and more skilled at the
art of defense.
So even though, in this hypothetical situation,
Naruto would be the Hokage, his claim to mastery
is slowly dissipating as the villagers come
to master the skills that supposedly define
his role as Hokage.
So who’s the master and who's the slave?